who do you think will be the top three
finishers in this event and you can
include yourself
well rapid and blitz I'd say maybe
Maxime Sasha and well I hope myself but
it's it's a very even field this year
and so it's much more than than before I
think well so a lot of players are
coming from Norway and some of those
players probably want to prove
themselves because they hadn't haven't
had a great event
in that case I'll pick Wesley and Maxine
myself okay let's do kayaking Nakamura
and myself I would say well I'm gonna
have to say myself
I'll put Levon in my top three and then
for the third one it's tough by I think
golf with Sergei sorry Magnus oh if I
read up here well recent forum and
definitely has to be Fabiano obviously I
cannot neglect myself as a great player
then comes next
Maxime he's very good in Blitzen Rapids
let me choose Chikara Nakamura cause he
generally ends high in the repeat of
listeners I'll pick him out a cuesta so
because he seemed to be in good shape
lately and then I will take shaggy
correction because he's had a very bad
result recently and he's a very good
place player okay I think it's issue one
of the Russian I think the kayaking or
girl shook one of this side not easy for
missing who and I think Nakamura and so
clearly in the camera Anand and one more
I don't know maybe we should me myself a
shock
mommy Europe and a niche and it's giving
because an expiry is very stable player
think last year we finished fourth place
and you know on a good term and you can
do really well
I mean it's really tough thing to us
because I think basically any of the
tent I just could have could have an
argument there but what I'm current from
I'm still going to pick Fabi and then
the cover has always been solid in you
know up it formats oh I think I'm gonna
pick him as well and then what I'm gonna
pick myself because I'm an optimist
[Music]